since the nuclear deal was signed
back in 2015 the u.s navy has seen a
significant increase
in the harassment from swarms of iranian
small boats in the persian gulf
these encounters put lives and shipping
at risk
in one instance in april 2017
the uss mahan fired warning shots and
had to make
dangerous changes of course to avoid
hitting one of these vessels
why does iran do this while this
behavior may appear to be strictly
aggressive
tehran actually has a very weak
conventional navy and it's dependent on
its
asymmetric frankly guerrilla style naval
forces
to deter more powerful adversaries like
the us
regardless washington needs to respond
more firmly
and continue investing in new
technologies like the longbow hellfire
missile
which can shoot out several missiles in
sequence to ensure the safety of our
personnel
and freedom of navigation in the persian
gulf
to learn more about my takes on iranian
strategy and military power
check the links in the description below
also let us know what other topics you
want aei scholars to cover
in 60 seconds